yeah I think it's a really good idea I
mean there's a risk obviously isn't
there that would something like this
that this is of great interest to people
like you and me that we care about
broadcasting we care about politics the
combination is really interesting to us
but actually when you go back and you
remember 2015 and 2017 more recently the
issue of the debates the question of
whether or not the people voting are
gonna get a chance to see their
potential prime minister quizzed and
tested really matters and and the
problem that we faced in 2015 and in
2017 was that politicians inevitably
played politics with it and so I think
what Skye is doing if you remember back
in 2010 it was Skye that made the case
for the TV debates in the first case the
first place I think what Skaar is doing
is come out saying let's organise this
now so we're out of the heat of the
campaign's and we can actually make it
happen and you know the BBC and Sky and
channel 4 and ITV everyone worked really
hard to make it happen in 2015 this
would make sure that it happened and the
rules were clear and the participation
was clear and what about the mechanism I
mean the mechanism is obviously setting
up off the Commission but I had to get
the Commission set up given that the two
leaders of the two main parties are the
same two leaders who refused to debate
her dad back in 2017
well Theresa May said right from the
outset
she wouldn't participate Jeremy Corbyn
actually did participate in the 2017
debates the thing to remember is that if
if the argument starts now the argument
is not about who's going to win the
argument is about politics and public
trust it's about saying we want to make
sure that all of our politicians reach
the largest number of people possible
and it seems really hard at least to me
for a politician for a party leader to
say in principle I'm against putting my
manifesto my ideas to the British public
and so the reason why I think it's a
good idea now is it's before the
campaign consultants of God in its
before the heat of the campaign it's
about talking in principle about the
health of our democracy and I know that
sounds a little grand but that's what
it's about Murrow logs have been drawn
with I suppose the Independence of the
Bank of England once the politicians
grasp the nettle and say right you're
gonna set interest rates and we're gonna
have nothing to do with it I mean it's a
very different thing but it then
persists forevermore and it becomes
commonplace within the nation it did I
mean look if you go back to your history
what happened of course in the United
States was that there was a presidential
debate and then the politicians got
their hands on it and said no we don't
want to do any more of that until an
independent commission was established
and there was a really important set of
principles that underpin that one was
the public's access to their potential
leaders but there was also confidence
and trust in broadcasters in the media
and I think we should you know look at
ourselves in this and say if there is
someone independent who is establishing
the rules establishing who participates
how long they answer for the questions
that are asked there's also a chance
here for the public to say there's no
politics being played in the media
either this is squarely and and simply
about making sure we hear what the
options are here what the choices give
us your sense though of the horse
trading that goes on behind the scenes
trying to set up unsuccessfully trying
to set up one of these leaders debates
and at the core of it this calculation
particularly by the incumbent about how
much they have to lose we think back to
2010 Gordon Brown was behind in the
polls and more or less took the view
I've got nothing to lose here I might as
well have a go and that usually isn't
the situation so you're exactly right
2010 if you like was the anomaly it was
the accident of history when Gordon
Brown said well we might as well and
suddenly the door opened you remember
Tony Blair had not wanted to take part
in in leaders debates the problem in
2015 was that the four big broadcasters
the BBC ITV channel for Sky we all got
together and we will absolutely
committed and in fact for all of our
competitiveness we really worked in a
concerted way to make sure some format
of debates happened and indeed it did
the problem was that the prime minister
of the day David Cameron didn't want to
do it and he didn't want to do it for
two reasons personally if you go and ask
him he just didn't want to do
he found the whole experience absolutely
nerve-wracking and secondly politically
he didn't want to he thought I have all
of the weight and all of the recognition
of Prime Minister why do I want to put
myself if you like on equal footing with
all of those other politicians that
would be Prime Minister's and the
leaders of smaller parties I will shrink
in the public's esteem and so the battle
was just you know in every conceivable
way getting some kind of debate that
involved all parties to happen and we
got somewhere in the end but we didn't
get what you know we set out to do in
2010 and what I think everyone is
talking about today which is proper
debates that involved the potential
prime minister of this country so you
think I just wanted to pick you up on
that so if it does happen you think it
should be presidential it should be head
to head one against one well I think the
thing that's brilliant about the UK you
know and we should actually celebrate
this is we've got an incredibly robust
and lively media there are loads of
great programs you know personally I
happen to think the question time is an
amazing way for testing and for the
public to ask directly what they think
of their politicians you know you know
sky heaven knows has asked you know
pointed questions of politicians there
are a range of different programs and
none of those had been taken off the
table what we're saying is there should
though be a moment where the public can
look and see who might be the prime
minister who might decision make
decisions of war and peace who might
oversee the budget that seems to me to
be the right formulation for a public
television debate of our leading
politicians